foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday March 3rd I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
at investor day Tesla Executives kept
bringing up one particular goal 20
million electric vehicles a year let's
talk about how we get to 20 million we
want to go to 20 million cars a year the
electric car maker has a long-term
ambition to sell 20 million Vehicles a
year
to do that it has plans that include
building new manufacturing facilities
getting involved in the production of
battery cells and of course selling more
cars worldwide but Elon Musk and his
electric vehicle company are facing
growing competition from other
automakers and speaking to investors
this week at its Austin area-based
Factory the company offered few
near-term details on how it plans to
achieve this lofty long-term ambition
joining us from Texas to discuss what
Tesla did say about its future and how
investors are reacting is our Tesla
reporter Rebecca Elliott hi Rebecca
thanks for joining us hi Zoe thanks for
having me so Tesla has this long-term
goal of becoming the world's biggest car
maker by volume Rebecca how does it plan
on doing that you're right so Tesla for
a while now has been aiming to sell 20
million Vehicles a year by 2030 and for
context the company delivered around
1.3 million vehicles to customers last
year and if it were to reach this target
that really would be twice the volume
that today's biggest car company does
each year so a really ambitious Target
and Tesla this week spelled out for
investors
some of the ways it intends to cut costs
improve productivity things like that on
its path to achieving that and other
goals
imagine a goal like that is going to
cost the company a lot did they say how
much it might cost and how they're going
to pay for it yes actually the Chief
Financial Officer Zach kirkhorn laid out
his expectations for how much reaching
these longer term goals will cost and he
estimated that it would run from around
150 to 175 billion dollars and that
includes what he estimated to be around
28 billion dollars that the company has
already spent maybe this total
investment looks large I actually think
it's quite small relative to our
Ambitions and if you look at our 2022
operating cash flows and you you just
say well let's assume some modest growth
to that maybe not all that much but the
ability to pay for this level of
investment from the forecast that we
have is is very achievable for us
getting their delivery goals so is this
a reasonable expectation or did they
talk about getting over hurdles they
might have faced in the past Elon Musk
the company's CEO spoke to the
challenges certainly of scaling up this
much this quickly certainly it is an
extremely ambitious Target Executives
were clear in saying they think it's a
achievable but it does require the
company to maintain a very fast pace of
growth over the next several years
it seems to be an
are not cheap cars and the impact of
price on demand was something Elon Musk
acknowledged at the event let's take a
listen and we found that even small
changes in the price have a big effect
on demand very big
so that was a good thing to learn musk
says Tesla has learned that did he talk
about any plans to bring down costs or
introduce a lower priced vehicle Tesla
did not go into detail there they kind
of hinted at its next Generation vehicle
at various points during the
presentation but I think that was a big
disappointment for Wall Street coming
out of the event shares traded down on
Thursday morning after and
musk at the event
said essentially when asked about the
Next Generation vehicle now's not the
time Tesla would have a separate product
event about that because Tesla only has
what four vehicle models at the moment
it has four passenger vehicles it also
has a semi-trailer truck that it started
delivering last year and the
long-awaited Cyber truck pickup is
expected to hit the market later this
year
but all of those models are priced above
forty thousand dollars in the US and so
investors have been looking for the
company to enter a lower price point
which would expand the number of people
who could potentially buy a Tesla right
not everybody can afford a new vehicle
that costs more than forty thousand
right it can be a tall order for a lot
of people one of the other Frontiers
that they're entering is in the
production of materials for battery
cells for the batteries that Power
electric cars can you tell us a bit
about their plans to get into that Tesla
is obviously not the only company really
investing in making electric vehicles
right now there is a lot of competition
in the U.S in China and Europe and that
has
created a whole lot of demand
particularly for the materials that go
into the battery cells that Power
electric vehicles Tesla
for a long time has vertically
integrated meaning done more in-house
than many auto manufacturers and the
battery supply chain is no exception the
company has been working to make its own
battery cells and also this week spoke
to Investments that it's making further
up the supply chain it broke ground on a
lithium refinery in Texas and also is
working to build a battery materials
facility near its Factory here do the
analysts that you spoke to think that
some of these goals are feasible or that
there's any reason to doubt the Tesla
can do this look selling 20 million
Vehicles a year is extremely ambitious
there is no precedent for that and so
there is a healthy amount of skepticism
about the company's ability to achieve
that goal
that being said I think it's important
to keep in mind that Tesla over the
years has achieved a lot of things that
many people thought were impossible all
right that's our Tesla reporter Rebecca
Elliott Rebecca thanks for joining us
thanks for having me and that's it for
Tech news briefing this week tnb's
producer is Julie Chang we had
production assistants from Zoe Culkin
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
our executive producer is Chris sinsley
and I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
foreign